olá tudo bem com vocês
é um prazer estar aqui acho que é um
prazer poder ser um exemplo de alguém
que sonhou de alguém que sonha e hoje em
dia percebe que esse sonho ele só
consegue ser realizado porque existem
mais pessoas sonhando um sonho que um
dia eu pensei que fosse meu
só que foi um sonho de dentro para fora
e o sonho ele começa a partir do momento
que a gente consegue enxergar cada
pessoa que passa na frente dos nossos
olhos
como parte desse sonho e um dia eu
sonhei indo para uma festa há 16 anos
atrás que é exatamente a metade da minha
vida até agora eu baseado na na palestra
passada tinha vários ingredientes para
seguir uma carreira normal ou algo que a
gente já tivesse algum tipo de segurança
a segurança financeira que ela é
no fim das contas uma mentira porque o
que importa é a sensação que está tendo
no momento presente e o quanto aquele
sonho faz a gente acordar todos os dias
é a analogia que eu vim pensando a
semana foi bem corrida eu viajei pra
alguns lugares antes de chegar aqui eu
até considera essa palestra um modo
diferente porque geralmente eu tô na
frente de uma pista e eu não estou
falando falando através da escolha de
músicas né
e é a sensação que o caso em mim o que
eu consigo causar nas pessoas através de
um instrumento que é a própria música e
olhando todo esse passado
a idéia de conseguir transpor e ter a
coragem de seguir é o fato da gente não
tem o sonho como algo que a gente lembra
depois que a gente acordou um sonho
verdadeiro é o sonho que a gente
consegue lembrar todos os dias que é o
sonho que instiga a gente na hora de
acordar que é o sonho que move cada
pequena ação que a gente em algum
momento acha que não vai ter impacto
nenhum mas são as pequenas ações que vão
levando e construindo tijolo por tijolo
a vontade de transformar o mundo num
mundo bem melhor
a nova economia que que eu acabei de
aprender também é o que chamo da nova
era ea nova era ela é compartilhável a
nova era cheia de escolhas ea nova era
da a real sensação ea possibilidade da
gente realmente exercer uma tarefa e ser
feliz e cada tarefa que a gente exerce
ela deve ser somada a todas as outras
para que a gente consiga no fim das
contas ficar em paz porque o mundo
precisa de paz um sonho grande é um
sonho sonhado com amor e só sobre o amor
que a gente precisa seguir em frente e
acho que é o amor da família o amor por
exercer e se sente útil no mundo de hoje
é é a utilidade é você tratar a tudo ea
todos com o mesmo amor que a gente trata
a nós mesmos ou qualquer atividade que a
gente vai escolher então acabei vencendo
barreiras de ir para uma festa 16 anos
atrás pegar minha malinha e dentro dessa
linha carregar um sonho e naquele
momento eu tinha muitas dúvidas de como
seria o que eu ia fazer
muitos não acreditaram em comum como eu
ia chegar lá o que estava fazendo porque
o caminho de ser um dj e sem foi um
estereótipo de você virar com drogas
você lidar com um estilo mais diante de
viver e ao longo do tempo fui
conseguindo provar pra mim o contrário
disso e ao mesmo tempo antes de mais
nada sem um exemplo pra mim mesmo antes
de qualquer outra pessoa porque esse
universo que a gente vivia mental
a nossa saúde mental tem que tá boa a
gente tem que estar em paz ea gente tem
que fazer exercício pra isso pra gente
ser um líder
antes de mais nada de nós mesmos a gente
conseguir ter a gestão emocional que a
gente não aprende na escola
isso é capaz de através de um pequeno
sonho interno agente transformar esse
sonho em sonho de mais pessoas
e hoje eu vivo me sinto dentro desse
sonho vivo dentro desse sonho e é um
sonho que eu consigo me sentir útil
entregando felicidade entregando
presença entregando consciência através
da criação de experiências em festas
através das viagens então o que sempre
me me fascinou a poder estudar a partir
do momento em que houve a primeira a
primeira festa acontecendo foi o fato de
poder viajar o fato de sentir mais livre
e não ficar preso numa situação mental
em que eu fui ensinado a o que mostraram
que poderia ser o único caminho seguro e
ao longo do tempo eu fui conquistando
mais sonhos e ao mesmo tempo conseguindo
trazer pessoas pra no fim das contas
sonhar esse sonho junto e eu percebi que
quanto mais pessoas sonham mais a gente
consegue realizar mais pessoas a gente
traz para dentro e começa a criar um
exército da paz
um exército de pessoas conscientes
desperta
isso é um pouco da minha vida hoje eu
moro mais em hotel do que em qualquer
outro lugar por esse motivo para uma
viagem eu escolhi morar num hotel em são
paulo também então eu trato a cidade
como se fosse um turista tem que olhar
tudo com novos olhos tento sair da
rotina e eu acredito que todas as
rotinas são contrárias à vida seja
rotina no relacionamento seja rotina de
pensamento seja rotina no trabalho ou
seja a rotina de se alimentar sempre da
mesma coisa e buscar sempre a
alimentação de relacionamentos em que no
fim das contas a gente precisa estar em
movimento e hoje em dia o morar no hotel
ele
ele retrata o fato de me sentir em casa
também no aeroporto
e como a gente consegue sentir em casa
porque antes da casa tá fora a casa tá
dentro então eu aprendi a criar
ferramentas de meditação da prática de
yoga para me sentir em paz em qualquer
lugar que tiver e no começo das 33
viagens acho que eu fiz nos últimos oito
anos para tocar fora eu ficava bem
nervoso no aeroporto porque estava
sozinho não tinha mais a vida da mãe
eu não tinha dos meus amigos eu não
tinha o conforto de estar em algum lugar
que eu mesmo tinha as rédeas da situação
mas eu aprendi que a gente consegue
liderar nós mesmos a partir do momento
que a gente tem as rédeas internas da
nossa mente a gente consegue parar
respirar até aqui eu tô vindo fazer uma
coisa nova mas faz parte do sonho eu
sempre sonhei em poder palestrar o poder
falar e trocar a música que eu escolhi
uma festa pra palavras aqui que é o que
reforça a estudar me força a minha
autoconhecer e através disso eu consigo
ter paz no aeroporto e me senti em casa
como se eu estivesse lendo um livro com
as pernas esticadas numa grama inúmeras
experiências aconteceram é vários
desafios acho que a gente sempre tem
adversidades em tudo que a gente vai
fazer
o importante é como a gente lida com
isso
com um com o importante é a gente
encarar as pessoas que no fim das contas
a gente começava a culpar a entender que
não é a terceirização que vai chegar a
uma solução que simplesmente entender
que a gente é responsável por todos os
atos
a gente é a somatória de de tudo o que
acontece com a gente a gente escolhe o
que a gente pensa
e essas coisas acabaram num ensinando na
escola né eu acho que nessa escola da
nova economia da nova era da escola da
vida onde a gente tem escolha ea gente
tem um mapa maior sobre como a gente
consegue gerenciar nossas emoções como a
gente perde o medo do dinheiro como a
gente consegue ter um artista e ao mesmo
tempo uma veia empreendedora
eu ao mesmo tempo nunca deixei de fazer
uma faculdade
nunca deixei de fazer um curso de
empreendedorismo e ao mesmo tempo
conseguir manter de uma maneira
equilibrada o fato de pagar um darf ou
de começar uma empresa do zero e também
tem a parte artística que era o fato e o
sonho de tocar que é onde eu me movo o
meu lance a tocar é tocar o coração das
pessoas a me tocar através da música
eu sabia que para ser um artista
completo eu precisava até a outra parte
ea outra parte é o fato de empreender
lidar com certas situações estereótipos
que um artista normalmente acaba
querendo escapar
então acha que eu sou artista possa
acordar tarde não eu de segunda à quinta
corda 67 da manhã pratica yoga faço
meditação tome as vitaminas mesmo
morando no hotel tento não comer o pão
todo dia porque sei que no fim das
contas ele vai levar a algum lugar -
saudável
esses são os ambientes que eu vivo hoje
em dia então eu consigo tocar desde uma
prática de yoga e criar essa situação
para as pessoas e não fica muito difícil
porque eu já vivo o yoga também eu
escolhi músicas com a facilidade que a
gente tem das ferramentas as músicas de
yoga então num evento de yoga ele é
muito parecido com uma festa só que as
pessoas estão praticando yoga e eu estou
criando a parte sonora e isso a gente
acaba transformando num evento e 16 anos
atrás eu sonhei em ser de dia e 16 anos
atrás eu sonhei em ter uma festa ea
festa o amor por criar uma comunidade ea
proximidade com o ser humano
e hoje o que mais me fascina não é
escolha música
o que mais me fascina a relação humana
de estar junto e me reconhecer através
de cada pessoa que eu olho no olho que
eu converso que me elogia que me critica
e isso me faz sonhar cada vez mais de
uma maneira maior né sonhar sonhar
grande a sonhar com mais pessoas e isso
tem acontecido em todos os âmbitos em
todos os momentos da minha vida aqui é
um é quase que um retrato de de tudo o
que eu vivi e o como o como é importante
a gente ter o equilíbrio entre sport o
equilíbrio entre o artista empreendedor
em tudo que a gente quiser fazer ter a
responsabilidade é a liberdade que a
gente busca ela requer responsabilidade
a gente tem que sair da nossa zona de
conforto porque esta ainda da zona de
conforto que a vida começa e
a zona de conforto ela é uma mentira
porque no fim das contas quem se acomoda
parece que está passando o tempo ea vida
sentada no sofá e o que a gente precisa
está em movimento é agregar mais pessoas
e e acho que quanto mais verdade a gente
gente tem mais mais força de elo de
ligação entre os seres humanos a gente
cria e 16 15 anos atrás foi criada uma
festa a primeira festa que eu toquei
fora do meu quarto
então eu passei dias e fui atrás de
curso fui atrás de todas as situações
que pudessem trazer conhecimento para
que eu conseguisse exercer uma clareza
aquela função e ao mesmo tempo que eu
era um produtor da festa é o dj da festa
então eram dois caminhos para ser muito
bem assim divididos e ao longo desses
anos
essa festa virou uma empresa essa
empresa hoje a gente tem leilão de
festas que vão desde o evento de yoga
até 1 um simples fato de organizar uma
viagem revelou na bahia outras
experiências das pessoas né
há quatro anos a gente criou o que eu
consigo me enxergar depois de todos
esses anos de experiência que é o sábado
de tarde onde eu consigo tocar seis
horas seguidas e onde eu também não
consigo imaginar o porquê que pular três
mil quilos de corda todo o dia fazer
yoga ia dar em alguma coisa e é o
exemplo claro de conseguir trocar a seis
horas seguidas sem tomar uma gota de
álcool e mais empolgado do que quando eu
cheguei eu termino sem dor do corpo
porque também tem a parte da disciplina
e responsabilidade de praticar o esporte
diário 'prática um coaching que eu faço
há sete anos e também consegue meditar é
e através disso cria se essa situação
onde eu consigo transpor os sentimentos
e ea paz através de uma festa que todo
mundo no começo falava que seria um
pouco difícil porque o universo de festa
muito vincado a droga porque o universo
de festa
eram pessoas mais inconscientes e há
quatro anos e isso nasceu no quintal de
uma casa com 300 pessoas hoje a gente
tem praticamente 4 mil por edição e só
tem crescido o processo vai levar para
mais estados e levar pra para diferentes
pessoas o a música é o que me move o que
o que é um sonho grande sonho grande
está desenvolvendo cada vez mais essas
pessoas com arte com música e eu encaro
muito como se fosse uma missa uma missa
transformado em festa só que do jeito
mais liberal possível onde tem todo tipo
de gente e existe uma coisa em comum que
é todo mundo em paz todo mundo o
presente que mais importa hoje em dia a
gente está presente e esquecer um pouco
do passado é trabalhar o futuro no agora
e lá eu consigo ver uma pista cheia e
hoje em dia uma pista cheia de
consciência e é muito interessante você
vê uma pista você observa ninguém está
conversando com todo mundo dentro de si
mesmo é aí que a gente consegue lembrar
daquela parte do aeroporto onde a gente
está bem com a gente mesmo que a gente
vai conseguir também com externo se a
gente tiver bem organizado com o interno
então a gente passa mensagens de de
felicidade cria um movimento semanda
momentos antes da festa antes dos
eventos e tentar trazer essa consciência
para tudo e para todos todas as partes
que a gente a gente pensa com design que
eu fiz faculdade onde pensa no início no
meio e no fim da criação de um de uma
idéia de uma decoração o carnaval foi
uma vontade de também saindo um pouco do
dos números de uma festa de venda de
ingresso ou de qualquer coisa que
engloba se esse negócio era poder
entregar para a cidade um lugar onde a
gente pega trânsito às vezes está
envolvido numa numa situação de ter que
chegar no trabalho tem que chegar uma
reunião está atrasado pegar uma avenida
como a faria lima
vai conseguir fazer o maior investimento
que eu tinha feito até agora e nunca
tinha feito que envolve dinheiro então a
parte artística minha concedida com
dinheiro de uma maneira mas que precisa
aprender a lidar e foi um investimento
muito interessante porque a gente tem
hoje em dia
depois de dois anos realizando e 14 anos
sonhando um dos maiores blocos de música
eletrônica da cidade
e aí pode velhinho pode criança
ele é totalmente democrático e e tem uma
liberdade de expressão essa é a que eu
nunca usei isso aqui de laser mas aqui
essa é a foto da faria lima no carnaval
desse ano então eu acho que deve ter ido
mais de 100 mil pessoas e foi um bloco
de música eletrônica que a gente
conseguiu quebrar os paradigmas também
onde tinha gente de todas as idades e ao
mesmo tempo todo mundo se sentindo bem
com a música eletrônica não é é através
da música através de trazer essa essa
paz né
não queria hoje em dia certas certas
formatos de show onde eu consigo trazer
um músico ao vivo também quebrar o
paradigma de que uma música mecânica não
poderia ter músicos junto então tem
saxofone hoje em dia tocando junto tem
violino tem voz
eu chego numa era que lá atrás eu
sonhava eu sabia que muitas coisas
deveriam ser feitas antes de o
concretizar o grande motivo do meu sonho
que era poder produzir música e esperei
14 anos para que isso acontecesse eu
tentei burlar um pouco esse caminho
tentando construir um estúdio há oito
anos e acho que o exemplo que eu tenho o
exemplo que que eu sou é que a gente
precisa ter paciência também às vezes a
gente é criado um sistema onde tudo tem
que nascer da noite para o dia e não é
da noite para o dia que algo realmente
fica grande
um sonho grande no universo que a gente
vive é totalmente mental ea gente tem
que ter base na mente para ter paciência
ea certeza de que a gente está realmente
conseguindo construir algo que vá ficar
como legado que vai ficar pra história e
com um
nesses 14 anos sonhando hoje em dia
consigo concretizar a partir de um
estúdio na cobertura do hotel que eu
moro e de lá vão sair mantras vão sair
músicas que vão alimentar tanto a parte
de yoga
quanto à parte de de transformar o dj
que eu sempre fui agora um artista então
esse sonho que a gente está falando tem
15 anos
eu imagino que isso vá pôr mais o tempo
que estiver vivo e imaginando um sonho
com uma árvore
hoje em dia os garis os frutos as folhas
arraes que vai para baixo o tronco vai
pra cima são mais pessoas sonhando junto
e hoje não é sobre criar um sonho é
sobre o que todo mundo que trabalhou
todo mundo que usufrui dos eventos que a
gente produz
então aí
e assim tem gente vai passar pra todo
mundo um e mail com um com as previstas
que eu tenho também que ajuda muito
então ao longo desses anos e fui criando
playlists para fazer um esquenta para
uma balada para viagens de carro que eu
adoro fazer então um link com marca que
eu aprendi ao longo desses 15 anos que é
tão importante quanto o seu lado
artístico ea liberdade artística e como
a gente usar marcas a nosso favor também
é quando você tem uma grande ideia
geralmente você também precisa de ajuda
de marcas para que aquilo se concretize
para que aquilo se realize
e essas são as três características de
som que eu me defino hoje em dia então
24 horas por dia ou escutando música
praticamente e ela se divide esses três
pilares eo de meditação é um é onde eu
pratico yoga e onde e muita gente hoje
em dia fala pra mim que escuta no
trânsito também pra conseguir ficar em
paz para tentar calmamente com mais uma
ferramenta a gente tem um programa de
rádio também então esse sonho vai
desabar o chamdo e quanto mais pessoas
têm sonhando junto mais sócios você tem
um negócio o outro ao longo do tempo
essas viagens transformaram em conteúdos
para a marca também então a língua
portuguesa fornece esse espaço entre o
d&o e colocar o rq seria o andré no meio
e viagens primeiro no profissão repórter
já acompanhou a gente que é o festival
nos estados unidos são 70 mil pessoas
que não encosta no dinheiro durante sete
dias e é um lugar que eu aprendi muito
me humanizar a olhar no olho das pessoas
e se sente responsável por tudo que
acontece com a gente que é o que está
falando há um tempo atrás as entrevistas
de mostrar o mundo dos djs de uma
maneira descontraída
então ao longo desse tempo eu não
comecei a me contentar mais em tocar
simplesmente numa balada e simplesmente
sonhar em tocar em um festival ou ser um
dj famoso simplesmente tocar o coração
das pessoas e tocar tocar o o lado mais
humano é o de construir uma cidade ou de
modificar uma sociedade e poder permitir
seu exemplo claro que todo mundo tem o
direito de sonhar grande e além de
sonhar realizar em seu pé a principal
mensagem do que do que eu me sinto apto
a fazer e através do amor que a gente
consegue evoluir e causar uma revolução
então essas são mensagens que a gente
passa nos eventos também e eu não sei
questão de tempo como a gente tá
esquisito infinito né
e eu acho que é isso é só um evento de
meditação que a gente tem todas as
ferramentas possíveis para que a gente
consiga trazer consciência do meu papel
cada vez mais eu vejo de trazer isso
através da música de festas e de ser um
exemplo de um equilíbrio é basicamente
isso obrigado
[Aplausos]